Скільки коштує гречка, скільки пшениця, чи той… цукор! Скільки м'ясо коштує!
Киянин Анатолій ділиться своїми враженнями від цін на ринку.
Йому треба закупити харчів на чотирьох - живе з дружиною, тещею і песиком.
Ось для собачки корму купив і трошки м'яска взяв. Я брав індичку,
якщо стегно брати, то воно коштує десь 170 гривень кілограм.
Ну, ціни піднялися… Я думаю, ще більше піднімуться.
Анатолій каже: продукти - найбільша стаття витрат у щомісячному сімейному бюджеті.
Доларів 600 виходить сто відсотків, це десь тисяч 15 точно.
Це десь половина від сімейного бюджету. Це я ще комуналку не рахую,
45 квадратних метрів квартира - це три тисячі виходить з опаленням, з усіма ділами.
Дійсно, продукти за останній рік значно здорожчали.
У 2021 році інфляція (а це і є показник зростання цін) сягнула
найвищого показника за останні чотири роки - 10 відсотків.
Яйця здорожчали, я люблю яйця купувати. Вони по 30 з чимось гривень зараз.
Та дуже подорожчало, я тільки по хлібу можу сказати, що подорожчав
гривні на три - це точно.
І м'ясо подорожчало, і все подорожчало набагато.
Не розумію, чому воно все дорожчає? Ціни роблять європейські,
а пенсії - я навіть не знаю які.
Подорожчання продуктів - це загальносвітова тенденція.
Німеччина, Великобританія, Іспанія зафіксували рекордні показники інфляції за 30 років.
Зростання цін у світі пов'язують з ефектами локдаунів, а головне -
з подорожчанням енергоносіїв.
В Україні додаткового удару по економіці завдала військова напруга
на кордонах з Росією. Аби боротися зі зростанням цін, уряд спершу
зобов'язав приватні компанії продавати газ виробникам так званих
соціальних продуктів з обмеженою націнкою. А потім наказав
роздрібним торговцям продтоварами обмежити націнку на соціальні продукти -
не вище 10 відсотків. Економісти вважають державне регулювання помилковим кроком.
Зобов'язати магазини продавати по заниженій ціні - це фактично
примушувати їх відмовлятися від свого заробітку, навіщо їм це робити?
Вони просто не будуть продавати.
У нас уже дуже багато було криз із цінами на продукти. Тоді діяли так само
- всі ці механізми регулювання цін, обмеження надбавок, але по суті
воно ніяк не впливало на кінцеву ціну. Якщо є спроба завищити націнку
на рівні роздрібного торговця, то вони завжди це зроблять.
Бо це договори в різні сторони. Наприклад, виробник отримує гроші
від роздрібної мережі за продукцію і одночасно платить за краще місце на полиці,
за акції і так далі. І вони завжди домовляться, щоб там було все написано,
як прописано в постанові кабміну. Тому ніколи воно не мало ніякого впливу,
і врешті-решт воно було скасоване, тому що аналіз показав, що воно не працює.
У керівництві держави замислилися над ще одним варіантом
пом'якшення цінового удару - так звані "продуктові картки".
Як "єПідтримка" за вакцинацію - так і "підтримка" на їжу.
Ідея належить раднику президента Олегу Устенку.
Якщо від інфляції потерпають всі групи споживачів, а в тебе є обмеження бюджетне,
тобто немає коштів щоб підтримати одразу і всіх, давати субсидії
наліво, направо, спереду і ззаду, то ти маєш сконцентрувати допомогу
на найбільш вразливі верстви населення. В моєму розумінні це інвалід,
який живе на мінімальну соціальну допомогу, це мати-одиначка,
яка виховує дитину, це людина, яка з інвалідністю і щойно її отримала
і просто не має інших доходів для існування, це людина, яка втратила роботу
і потребує додаткової тимчасової допомоги.
Наразі це лише ідея - без конкретних сум і механізмів. І все ж у людей
вона вже викликає неоднозначні реакції.
Не знаю, як воно буде, це нове щось хочуть ввести.
Було б добре, але так дивно… - Скористалися б? - Ну так, звичайно.
- А скільки б хотіли, щоб вам держава давала? - Ну три тисячі хоча б,
ну це для мене, я тільки з дочкою живу.
Я вважаю, що це не спасе нашу ситуацію з цінами, навіть якщо будуть якісь картки.
А як визначити, хто малозабезпечений? Розумієте, коли малозабезпеченим
буде субсидія на картки на продукти, а хто не малозабезпечений?
Він заплатить комунальні послуги, і що в нього залишиться?
Ми вже були на картках, ми знаємо, що це таке - черги кілометрові,
а візьмеш чи не візьмеш - невідомо.
Радник президента Олег Устенко радить називати ініціативу не "продуктовими картками",
а радше "програмою допомоги малозабезпеченим верствам населення"
і не порівнювати з радянськими часами.
Це геть не має нічого спільного з тими продуктовими картками,
які були в Радянському Союзі і закінчилися ще в 50-их роках,
бо природа цих карток в принципі різна. Тоді картки були - це йшлося
про розподіл продуктів в умовах тотального дефіциту, а зараз
мова йде про будь-які програми по підтримці
малозабезпечених верств населення при тому, що в магазинах є повно продуктів.
Українська ініціатива - радше аналог програми Food Stamps, яка існує в США
ще з 1960-их років. Зараз вона передбачає видачу пластикових карток
з коштами, які можна витратити лише на низку товарів.
Сума визначається залежно від доходу домогосподарства.
Чи можна таку ж систему налагодити в Україні? Експерти сумніваються.
Якщо ми пробуємо побудувати аналогію з системою єПідтримка,
це легко реалізувати через випуск спеціальних карток з обмежень
так званим МСС-кодам банківських терміналів. Тобто в них вказано,
який це тип закладу - книгарня, театр чи аптека. Уявіть таке саме за кодом
продуктового магазину. Там "Ашан" гігантський або "Метро"
і навіть маленька крамничка, куди умовно багата людина,
якщо їй дати ці гроші, прийде і купить пляшку "Хеннесі". А навіть якщо
ми старгетуємо це на бідних людей - окей, так само може прийти і купити пляшку горілки.
Це люди надихнулися "ковідною тисячею", але там був чіткий критерій
- вакцинувався не вакцинувався, і людина, маючи сертифікат,
отримує цю тисячу. А бідність і нужденність - це трошки важча категорія
для визначення. Враховуючи те, що в нас Мінсоц не може створити базу пільговиків,
то тут є сумніви, що програма food stamps - продуктових карток -
буде ефективна. Яскрава - так, шумна - так, з приводу ефективності - великі питання.
Замість нових програм, які потребуватимуть часу, фахівці радять розширювати ті,
що вже існують - наприклад, систему субсидій. Адже за прогнозами економістів,
у 2022 році ціни на продовольство у світі подовжуватимуть зростати.